قالت الرئيسه التنفيذيه للجنه حمايه
الصحفيين جودي جزن بررج ان حرب اسرائيل
على غزه هي الاكثر فتكا وقتلا للصحفيين
وشددت جينسبرج في حديث مع الجزيره على انه
يجب الا يستهدف الصحفيون في غزه كما فعلت
اسرائيل وكان المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي في
غزه اعلن ارتفاع عدد الشهداء من الصحفيين
الى
122 منذ بدء الحرب الاسرائيليه على القطاع
ليس مسموحا لاسرائيل ان تقتل الصحفيين
والمدنيين وكان ينبغي تقديم الحمايه لهم
بموجب القانون الدولي نحن في لجنه حمايه
الصحفيين دعون اسرائيل للتحقيق في مزاعم
بشان جرائم ضد الانسانيه وجرائم حرب ضد
الصحفيين صحيح اننا لم نرى هذا الاعتراض
من المجتمع الدولي كما نتوقع وقمنا بارسال
رسائل الى الرئيس بايدن والاتحاد الاوروبي
لحثه على القيام بالمزيد لضمان حمايه
الصحفيين